I think what matters the most is that no
person is subjected to a substandard
life
most important way I found that I can
use my voice to make a difference is to
write songs that matter poverty in the
u.s. is staggering one in seven people
are living below the poverty line and
most recent statistics say that a person
earning under twelve thousand dollars a
year is in poverty I mean twelve
thousand a year that's that's right
that's what can you do after we need to
be able to to develop better social
systems so that no person is left with
inadequate health care and adequate
education and adequate nutrition it's
just a basic human right basic human
necessities south la is considered a
food desert where there's little to no
access to fresh organic produce and the
most abundant market that people have
access to is a liquor store that sells
junk food and soft drinks my parents
come from Panama and they grew up
relatively poor they never really talked
about being hungry I remember my dad
complaining about palm trees in
California so there's palm trees
everywhere but they're useless he says
in Panama these are all coconut trees at
least you can eat the coconuts I find
that here we do a lot of cosmetic
vegetation just to look good but if we
can make real transformation you can use
these open spaces for vegetation that's
edible we can really transform the
spectrum of hunger the one thing that
gets me the most about the prison system
is how a lot of these private prisons
are popping up and it's a huge industry
to think that someone is profiting off
someone else's paying is just wrong we
have so many people in prison and in
jails because of arcane laws that were
created to be tough on crime but nobody
was tough on education nobody was tough
on job development nobody was tough on
support these are the things that we
need to be tough on
I think it's really important for
artists to use their platform to discuss
the issues that matter to human beings
if i can write a song that creates a
mantra that people can consider
themselves it helps them to to feel
motivated then i feel like i'm doing my
job